This is mos espa and i am daimyo here
Welcome back everyone this will be my full star
wars book of boba fett episode 2 video the sleeper
has awakened so we found out how boba fett joined
that tribe of tusken raiders there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs we found out who's going to be the
main villain for at least the first part of the
series if not the entire series so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
i'm doing videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get them we're also doing a giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is just be a subscriber and let me know
what your favorite moment from the episode was in
the comments careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs wtf moments as we
go along starting with the title chapter 2 the
tribes of tatooine a reference to the different
tribes of tusken raiders because boba fett joins
his tribal tuskens officially and is also sort
of a sly reference to the tribes of the criminal
underworld like the hutts that show up during the
episode jabba's cousins but mostly they're talking
about the different tribes of tusken raiders i
made a couple dune references during my episode
1 video there's so many dune references during
this episode i'll point them out as we go along
but you probably spotted some of the more obvious
ones a lot of lawrence of arabia references too
the opening scene is a fennec shan bringing the
assassin they captured back to jabba's palace so
boba fett can question him they say he's from the
order of the night wind and set up this big trap
door rank or pit joke because you can't do jabba's
palace you can't have him sit in the throne room
there without them using the trapdoor at some
point but if you've seen return of the jedi which
most people on the planet have you know that luke
skywalker killed the rancor so they played the
scene the same way they played that luke skywalker
scene with the door just rising up slowly but
obviously you know that there's nothing there in
the assassin reveals what we all suspected after
episode one that he's connected to mock chaise
although they try to play it in a more complicated
way blaming the hutts for everything later in
the episode the order they say he belongs to the
night wind didn't exist in star wars before this
so they created it for the episode there were a
couple creatures and terms that they created brand
new for this episode that didn't exist before so
i'll point those out too as we go along but if i
didn't say it during my episode 1 video matt berry
from what we do in the shadows is the one who's
doing the voice of the ada droid so if he sounded
familiar that's why if you're wondering why bib
fortuna never replaced the rancor with another one
i think what they were trying to establish during
episode one when boba fett was just first going
around to survey all of jabba's territory is
that bib fortuna was very bad as a crime lord
in rancors are native to dathomir where the night
sisters come from so it's incredibly hard to
capture a young one and take it back in captivity
like the young rancor that the bad batch saves
for jabba during the bad batch series was one of
his most prized possessions but they go back to
moses to visit the mayor with the assassin in tow
they pass a bunch of transoceans and everyone's
hoping for a boss cameo scene but there are like
so many of them grouped together in this part of
town that you just wonder if they're trying to
foreshadow bosk eventually showing up they have
a couple funny jokes about people not knowing boba
fett's name like oh you're on the list here what's
your name again boba what boba who as if he's
not the most famous bounty hunter in the galaxy
the major domo mentions jabba's litter again as
if everyone and their sister on tatooine only
recognizes new crime lords if they're floating
around on litters but i also think this is meant
to set up the payoff of jabba's cousins showing up
the twin showing up on the actual litter so that's
why they've been mentioning the litter so many
times in the last couple of episodes but like i
said last week robert rodriguez the director is
also playing the mayor here the ithorian who is
this who enters unannounced so this is his second
cameo scene and second character on the series
we'll see if he shows up as other characters in
later episodes too that would be fun if he winds
up playing like five different characters in the
series the armor that his guards are wearing looks
kind of similar to the armor that captain panaka
wore in phantom menace a movie that also spent a
lot of time on tatooine in most espa where we are
here because that's where jabba held the pod races
the mayor tries to save face by paying boba fett
as if he's paying him for a bounty like oh it's
illegal for them to operate out of hud space so
here let me pay you the bounty as if this is meant
to be recompensed for the tribute that he did not
give him and he tries to throw the hutts under the
bus like oh think who might hire them if they only
operate in hutt space maybe it was the hutts but
that's why he tells him to go visit madame garco
whip again the twilight played by jennifer beals
who owns the bar and i know a lot of people were
wondering if there was something secret going on
with her character like is she hiding some giant
secret is she secretly way more powerful than she
lets on the way jennifer beals described her
character here is that she's like rick in casa
blanca and in that movie he owns this nightclub
it's sort of like a switzerland neutral type of
territory where he wields a lot of power inside
the bar like he has a lot of contacts on both
sides of the war but he himself isn't like the
secret big bad or anything like that so i think
that's jennifer beale is trying to tell us that no
she's not secretly some huge villain but she does
have deep connections she is very smart and she is
powerful in her own right in this local area here
but she's not evil or anything like that like
she's not out to get boba fett when he says that
she's sweating like a gupta on mustafar guptas
are also a brand new creature that they created
for this episode they didn't exist in star wars
before but you get the metaphor it's meant to be
like a cold weather animal that wouldn't be able
to survive in the heat of mustafar's lava fields
and when she says the twins are coming to claim
their late cousin's bequest obviously they're
talking about jabba the hutt's cousins coming to
claim his criminal empire which they feel belongs
to them like if you died your nearest living
relatives would fight over your will and they
do show up with a tablet which seems like a star
wars version of a will canonically none of jabba's
cousins were twins but he did have two different
cousins from different uncles so ziro the hutt
from the clone wars you all probably remember only
had one son and his other canonical uncle ibor the
hutt didn't have any known children so the twins
could just be the children of zeri and they could
have just changed the canon for this episode
but the twins are a brand new thing to star wars
and i will say the cg for the hutts has gotten way
better since the special editions of the original
trilogy and phantom menace they're much younger
than jabba so they're not quite as big as he was
but together they're about as big as he got right
before his death in return of the jedi and you do
have to feel bad for this hodgepodge menagerie
of different aliens serving them carrying them
on their backs like that's got to give them some
serious back problems after this then the wookie
is actually a huge deep cut easter egg for the
star wars canon so it's actually black krystan
he's a wookie bounty hunter that's featured a lot
in the comics during the timeline of the original
trilogy like the dr aphra comics when boba fett
starts talking about being a gladiator that's
a reference to black kirsten's backstory being
captured from kashyyyk he started out being forced
to become a gladiator in fighting pits but then
he became a bounty hunter working for job of the
hunt working for darth vader to capture agents
of the emperor he hunted obi-wan kenobi but if
he didn't get the vibe just from looking at him he
is meant to be a badass he is legit when boba fett
references the death pits of dir that's also a
brand new planet that they just invented for this
episode they make another trandocin reference like
i said there's just so many of them sitting around
this area here you don't wonder they're trying
to foreshadow bosk eventually showing up later
in the series if they're doing so many bounty
hunters from the star wars universe now huda that
he talks about is the capital of the hutt empire
and for those of you that were complaining last
week that boba fett wasn't wearing his jet pack
and why would he go to town without a jet pack
you can clearly see that he did not repeat his
mistake this time jetpack with the rocket launcher
which we saw cobb van fuze a couple times during
the mandalorian season 2 episode 1. we should all
take bets on when boba fett's going to use his
rocket launcher on this series for the first time
you cannot tease that rocket launcher without
letting him use it at least once during these
episodes and the way he throws the gauntlet down
and jabba's cousins threaten his life like sleep
lightly makes it sound like they want you to think
at least right now that the two of them the twins
will be the main villains of this season but they
could always surprise us later with an even bigger
crime lord villain like you have crimson dawn
or whatever crimson dawn turned into after darth
maul's death or any of the other organizations
that made up darth maul shadow collective of crime
lords like we see the pike syndicate later in the
series too so there are a lot of other criminal
organizations around the galaxy that are very
powerful but it does make sense that they would
use part of jabba's family as villains during the
series given that boba fett is trying to currently
take over jabba's empire the funny reason why
fenix shan says they have to get permission to
kill the hutt twins is because of the treaty that
the hutts as a people have with the new republic
the hutts were kind of like a neutral group during
the galactic civil war between the empire and the
rebellion in a lot of the weapons and ships that
the rebels acquired came through the black market
in the hutts like the hutts were hedging their
bets so that no matter who won the war the rebels
of the empire they would benefit financially so
as a way to say thank you the new republic has a
loose treaty with them allowing them to continue
operating their business without being harassed
by the authorities too much within limits and as
part of that no one gets to go kill a hutt without
a bunch of paperwork so it is a little bit of plot
armor protecting the hutt twins because otherwise
boba fett probably would have killed them on the
spot but back in the box tank later they flashed
back to the tusken raider timeline after he got
out of the sarlacc pit after the events of episode
1 and they basically tell the rest of the story
about how he became part of their tribe they start
training him how to fight with the gaffy sticks
and the interesting thing here that you probably
didn't notice just from looking at their costumes
is the tusken raider who's training him throughout
the episode and who also has a bunch of badass
takedowns on the train later is a female tusken
raider yet to have female tusken raiders otherwise
where do you get those tiny little tusken raiders
from it's just that all the robes hide their
features so much you wouldn't know just from
looking at them i know everyone's wondering what
they look like under their mask there have been a
couple examples in the legends canon so this is
like the closest we have to what they probably
look like they do look humanoid and they do take
people in like boba fett joins their tribe so just
like the mandalorians aren't all born mandalorians
like some other people join their clans in the
case of boba fett occasionally other people will
join tribes of tusken raiders but all the gaffy
stick training just explains how he got so deadly
with it during the mandalorian season two against
the storm troopers and where he got his gaffy
stick from because we see him making it later in
the episode after he has his big paul etredes dune
water of life sequence the boba fett sleeper has
awakened the other funny thing about these too the
gaffy sticks is they serve a practical purpose as
well in their culture they use them for cleaning
the bantha's teeth so they're not just weapons
but this is all just part of him learning their
ways the creature that pops out of the sand that
runs off that they kill is called a booboo a
killer it's one of the frogs from return of the
jedi outside jabba's palace they're kind of like
frogs crossed with dogs they just literally call
them frog dogs then they said at the whole train
heist later in the episode when the pike syndicate
drives their train through the dunes sea and winds
up killing a bunch of their people and as you see
in the last couple of episodes they use this whole
sequence here them kind of mourning the dead that
funeral pyre to humanize them even more than they
did during the mandalorian episodes and they're
just showing you how boba fett is growing to
respect them more and more and how being with them
is slowly changing him his ways his personality so
if you feel like boba fett in the bopa vet series
is acting very differently from what you remember
a boba fett in the classic series this is why
because of his time spent with the tusken raiders
but as part of the train heist he goes after the
red nectos gang that you saw hurting the moisture
farmer in episode one to get their speeder bikes
in the bar where they're at here is a huge easter
egg for a deleted scene from a new hope when luke
goes to tashi station and anchor head talking
to big's dark lighter all of his other friends
this is the same room that boba fett walks
into that they're using as the bar obviously
they recreated the set for the episode but it's
meant to be the same basic place the gun breaking
on him just gives boba fett an opportunity
to put his new gaffy's stick skills to use
and i love the way that tuskens turn into a bunch
of jawas the minute he comes back to give them the
gift of the bikes like no no no please don't bust
these up for parts i'm going to teach you how to
ride so we can take down the train but in sort
of keeping with a lot of the dune references and
metaphors that they're going for during the series
a lot of star wars is inspired by the dune series
the train attack itself is meant to evoke imagery
of the fremen trying to board one of the sand
worms more literally it's also a reference to
lawrence of arabia and boba fett himself kind of
like the lawrence of arabia figure when they're
taking down the train in that movie like i said
the aliens who are controlling the train are from
the pike syndicate mostly you saw them during the
clone wars but they did show up during solo a star
wars story the tusken who jumps the ship later and
starts destroying all of them here is the female
one who was training him with the gaffy stick love
how the conductor droid also just eats out the
window after wrecking the engine so bad they're
about to blow up on their own they reference
spice which in the star wars universe is also
inspired by the spice melange from dune the planet
tatooine desert planet also inspired by arrakis
when the pike leader says he thought that they
were uncivilized raiders that's kind of how the
people in the dune series thought of the fremen
and that's the same way in the classic trilogy
that the tusken raiders were portrayed the way the
obi-wan kenobi talks about them to luke skywalker
they also have a clever way of explaining that
later in the episode too there are some of us
who survive by killing people other tribes try to
survive in a more peaceful way and boba fett sets
up that lasting deal for the tuskens to be paid
tolls by anyone trying to ship goods spice illegal
or otherwise through the dune sea in exchange
for their protection you can see they're really
trying to give the tusken raiders an arc during
this series the same way the freeman have a huge
arc during the dune series but is back at their
camp that the leader tells boba fett the history
of their people going back thousands of years
to the time when tatooine was covered in water
there's also some water references later during
boba fett's visions when he's tripping balls
so at one point tatooine was covered in water more
dune references like arrakis was covered in water
during the series the freeman talk about having
visions of it being covered in water again
and when boba fett says you shouldn't have to hide
your warriors they're trying to draw parallel to
the mandalorians that are living in the outer
rim who survived the purge like they've been
forced to hide until recently when mando reclaimed
the darksaber and they took down moff gideon but
clearly you can see he's trying to help modernize
them like oh you know other people outworlders
have technology but now you have technology too
you have ships you have speeder bikes they also
have the modern supplies the modern weapons that
they took from the pike syndicate then this whole
metaphysical mine trip that they send them on is
another dune reference to paula tradies taking the
water of life in the visions that he has the dust
the leader throws in his face is spice just like
the spice melange i love the joke about the lizard
climbing up his nose though like oh i thought that
i ate that meant to help guide him in a psychic
sense on this metaphysical journey that he goes
on as he flashes back through his past his present
and his future like this is meant to help him find
a new path obviously in present day we know
that that path involves taking over jabba's
former empire and becoming a crime lord himself
but that's only part of the story there were a
lot of people after episode 1 who are like why
why are they making boba fett a crime lord when
he's a bounty hunter like why would he want to be
a crime lord what's the whole point of this this
whole journey that he's going on with the tusken
raiders and how he's getting tied up in their
culture is meant to help explain that but i think
it'll take a couple more episodes before we find
out what his true plan is for the tusken raiders
in present day because all this stuff is happening
in the flashbacks but as he gets caught up in
the tree branches he flashes back to the sarlacc
pit he sees himself in his father jango fett's
helmet then he flashes back to kamino watching
his father fly away in the slave one also kind of
foreshadowing him taking the slave one back in the
flashbacks all the different red eyes that he sees
are the red eyes of the jawas then he has this
crazy vision of water bursting out of the sands
of the tatooine desert mixed with visions of him
escaping the sarlacc pit breaking free through the
sand and breaking free from the tree so they're
just trying to say that boba fett is going to
have a continuing relationship with the tuskens in
present day and because water is such a precious
resource for them the water bursting out of the
sands of tatooine i think is meant to be more of
a metaphor for the way that paula tradies say help
the fremen when he rose to power like boba fett
is going to rise to power as the crime lord taking
over jabba's territory and is going to use that
power to try and help the tuskens i've been making
a lot of dune references but i guess you could
also think of lawrence of arabia references with
this too the branch that he returns with he winds
up turning into his own personal gaffy stick that
we saw him use during the mandalorian season two
and this is sort of the continued process of him
officially becoming part of the tribe like this is
part of a rite of passage so if it wasn't clear in
the present day timeline the robes that he wears
underneath his mandalorian armor boba fett's
classic armor are the tusken raider robes in that
cool tribal dance that they do after is just meant
to be the celebration for him officially entering
the tribe like this is the end of the initiation
but if you spotted any other big easter eggs
or references in the episode that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in the
comments my full book of boba fett episode 3 video
will post next week just like normal and next week
the dc peacemaker hbo series will start too i'll
be doing episode videos for that make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss that we're also probably going to get a moon
knight trailer pretty soon too for the marvel stuff
that'll start after the book of boba fett is done
everyone click here for my brand new doctor strange
multiverse of madness marvel video and click here
for all my star wars book of boba fett episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!